okay hello everyone it's been a while
since I streamed maybe the longest that
I've gone without streaming for for the
last several months it's may have been a
week since I last streamed have to check
but I've been really busy I'm leaving
town tomorrow so I'm gonna fit in maybe
a few games I'd be very surprised if
this lasts longer than like half an hour
so if anyone wants to challenge me feel
free can use the challenge command
hello doe-eyed and hello to motes okay
we're gonna play all Brown not sure if I
play it all brown before oh I have about
three three zero score against all
around to play let's play you for if
anyone has opening recommendations for
you for let me know or bat-skis and in
Europe somewhere right
probably Poland sounds slightly polish
let's play Knight f3 I'm gonna play an
opening that I played oh never mind he's
playing the petrov okay I want to go for
a for Knights I wanted to play like the
molar attack which I haven't played in
ages but I'll go for this let's play d4
I don't usually play d4 like recently
I've been playing a3 very tricky move
let's weigh the bell great but what was
this called the Belgrade gambit with I'm
not taking back on d4 above playing
Knight e5 and I'll admit I know almost
nothing about this line the only thing I
know about this line is the best move
for black in this position which he
didn't play apparently the best move for
black is might be four but I assume this
should lead to some nice position for
whites after queen take tea for already
looking very pleasant it's no longer a
gambit
it's just having more space equal
material and now this is a move if he
moves the night anywhere
I have Queenie five check and I'll win a
piece if he plays queen 85 I have Bishop
d2 so I think blocks in trouble
Queenie five nice little trap the pollen
d6 is so strong when you check on the
e-file if something has to block Ani 797
such a sad move and I'm not gonna take
the knight there's no rush I would like
to uh just build up the position maybe
torture the opponent probably Bishop c4
here Bishop h6 would be a funny move but
I think that's over-the-top its way
Bishop c4 super major pain thanks for
joining and hello I don't know how to
pronounce that pollen factory poon
factory pun factory PW and how do you
pronounce pwn I was on a website today
it's helping a family member it's called
have I been poned or puns or something
to check whether like your account has
been hacked her or whatever I checked
like one of my old email addresses I
think I haven't used in ages and it's
apparently been hacked like six times
oh it's pone okay I assumed it was an O
cause it's like a typo where you you
mean to type O but you type the P
instead okay so he plays b6 looks very
uh non-threatening now I could take the
knight but of course I don't want to
take the Knights can I just play Knight
g5
how does he defend against f7
this is hilarious like his King has no
escape
this can't move this can't move and this
can't move like he okay he can move to
c7 but then if he moves to see suddenly
I take on that seven and its meaning to
I think this is just force mate like b6
was probably the worst possible move in
the position because it's made into
whatever he does unless I'm missing
something
it's incredible I should play the
Belgrade gambit more often
there's nothing to do here like he can't
block the bishop he can't
moving the pond is about seven such I
feel good game my opponent says rats
double exclamation points
and he wish me luck which I didn't even
realize but I guess the luck helped I
should have seven it's painful I feel
bad like causing my opponent so much
pain that's okay that was so much fun
for me I wonder if anyone's falling for
like the same line I mean the experiment
here hopefully this doesn't mess things
up oh it's probably gonna mess things up
but let me experiment oh it didn't mess
things up too bad like zoom in I just
wanted to like show people opening
Explorer let's just go back and then go
back to the main scene Oh cuz opening
Explorer is still here okay so there's
no reason for doing that but okay 95 is
yeah it's a tricky line and what the
other day Sam I using so masters
database not even the Masters know like
Bishop e7 is a solid moves but night
before I think is just a clear advantage
for black it's a hard move to find but
the point of night before is that after
was it after night take f6 Queen take f6
why can't take on d4 because of c2 so if
like night take d4 then there's Queen
take d4 so this is a actually a strong
response for black and in many of these
lines Bach just holds on to the pawn and
there's some line like 'if I've and
Queen b6 so what happened in the game at
taking can't be good even though it
looks natural just to trade but what
just gets a nice position than c6 is
just a blunder
probably d6 should be played so let's
see how many people fell into this on
each us everything's so high-scoring for
whites so d6 yeah I would just develop
normally and Bach is very slow to castle
uh if we go back
c6 has been played and then white plays
d6 and then Knight f5 okay so this has
happened in one game and white captured
which I mean it's capturing is fine but
oh wait a minute no 97 was played 97 and
black one in two games what they both
captured yeah there's never a reason to
take a piece that's pinned like right
away if you don't have to and in this
case I mean okay the knight is forever
attacked and yeah this is like maiden I
guess this is main than three Knight g5
yeah because the best best response is
Queen c7 to prolong the meet for one
move okay so that felt good I might just
make a youtube video out of that like
I'll cut the stream whatever I'll I'll
edit it maybe I'll clip out the moments
where I stuttered maybe not and then
I'll upload that to YouTube so there you
go for the YouTube viewers there's your
video and I'll see you guys in the next
video